it was a beautiful september day but
sean taylor was trapped in his car
in one of the worst cases of gridlock he
had ever seen
he tried to look on the bright side
though and while he was stuck
in an unmoving car at least he had a
pleasant view
of the wide shimmering lake just off the
road next to him
he was admiring the scene when tiny
drops of rain started landing on his
windshield
that's funny there wasn't a cloud in the
sky a moment ago
there was something off about the rain
though it looked dirty
a rusty red color was that blood
he didn't have time to think about it
because just then
a thick dense mist began to roll over
the lake
a fog of blood just off the side of the
road he could see a huge silhouette
rising out of the water is that an old
submarine
what sean didn't know was that he was
about to have an encounter with scp-1861
also known as the hms wintersheimer
a ghostly submarine with strange and
terrifying effects
shawn and the other drivers stuck in
traffic that day were far from the first
people to have a dangerous brush with
this legendary vessel
according to scp foundation records the
hms wintersheimer has been appearing
since as early as 1916.
the first recorded incident occurred in
the british seaside town of innsmith on
sea
you won't find this town on any maps or
in the history books
and you're about to find out why the 500
population of the town which had already
reduced by the wartime draft into the
currently raging great world war
awoke to red skies on february 6 1916
citizens left their homes to investigate
only to find
their entire town had been enveloped in
a thick
red mist the swelling crimson clouds up
ahead began to rain
showering the town in a hail of viscous
red goop
anyone unlucky enough to taste it would
say that this strange rain was a
dreadful mix of salt and copper
this was because as the foundation would
later determine
the rain and fog was a disgusting
combination of salt water
human blood and human cerebrospinal
fluid
but the real threat was rising just
beyond the beach
technically speaking the hms winter
shimmer vessel is designated as
scp-1861-a it appears to be a world war
one era british b-class submarine
designed by vickers for the royal navy
in 1904
by 1916 this particular type of boat was
already on its way to being obsolete
and were largely deployed in malta far
from the active fronts
so one of these vessels appearing on an
otherwise unremarkable stretch of
english coastline should have been a
clue
that something was terribly wrong but
the poor residents of innsmouth on sea
didn't know
the half of it soon figures in what
appeared to be archaic diving gear began
emerging from the wintershimer and made
their way into the township
they seemed terrified running up to and
frantically screaming at any local they
could find
please listen to me something terrible
is about to happen here
we need you to come with us so you're
all going to die you must believe us
the locals were frightened by what they
heard they'd been listening to news
reports of the great war unfolding
across the globe for two years now
had it finally come to them they
pictured shells raining down from the
sky
decimating their defenseless little town
in a reign of fire
the navy must have been brought in to
save them before the german bombardment
began
while some took more convincing than
others the men in diving suits
known as scp-1861-b
eventually managed to persuade the
entire town to join them
and lead the townspeople down to the
water one by one
they were all boarded onto the submarine
hundreds of them
many couldn't believe their eyes as they
watched scores of people disappear in
front of them
into the dark bowels of the winter
shimmer where were they all going
how would they all fit in there but it
was too late for any of them
to back out now the vessel submerged
once more
and everyone was gone the entire
population of innsmouth on sea
had disappeared in a rain of fog and
blood
never to be seen again the foundation
wiped all records of the town from
existence and delivered appropriate
amnestic treatment to anyone who still
mentioned or remembered innsmouth on
sea the fate of those who board the hms
winter shimmer
is always the same vanish from the face
of the earth
explained away by the foundation as
accidental death by extreme weather
event
there have been hundreds of documented
sightings of scp-1861
and the anomalous weather event can
occur near any body of water wide enough
to accommodate
scp-1861-a's coms tower and topmost
platform
depth does not seem to be any hinderance
of the submarine appearing
and it can even manifest in water that's
just a few
inches d as sean and the other
unfortunate victims of the rush hour
traffic were being showered in thick red
droplets from above
a crimson mist rolled in between the
cars
sean had heard of so-called freak
weather events before like raining frogs
and fish
but this was something different and it
frightened him
he could see now that the silhouette
rising from the lake really was an
old submarine and he watched as a legion
of mysterious figures disembarked from
the vessel and began spilling onto the
road
the men in ancient looking diving suits
walked among the cars and one of them
approached shawn's car
he began tapping frantically on the
window and sean could tell he was
yelling something
sean was scared and more but more than
anything else
he was confused against his better
judgment he rolled down the window just
a crack to hear what the man was saying
his british accented voice muted by the
diving suit
the man frantically told him sir please
listen to me
i'm lieutenant samuel ramsey of the hms
wintersheimer we're evacuating the area
please you've got to come with me we're
in danger out here
hms sean thought isn't that what they
call british ships
what was a british submarine doing in
the middle of a lake in the united
states
through his windshield sean could
already see other men in diving suits
leading people from the cars
out towards the submarine something had
to be going on here
something big lieutenant ramsay was
still banging away at the glass of
sean's window
becoming increasingly agitated sir if
you won't comply with my orders i'm
within my rights to take you by force
for your own safety
sean could feel the fear setting in but
he didn't know what else to do
he turned off the car and took off his
seatbelt he was just about
to open the door when there was a tap on
the passenger side window of his car
it was a soldier in what looked to be
advanced tactical gear
there were several soldiers directing
cars to drive on the shoulder to get
around the mess of stopped automobiles
sean looked to his left and the man in
the diving suit was gone
the soldier tapped again and sean didn't
need to be told twice
he followed his directions and drove
around the traffic jam and
out of the mist a half mile down the
road sean was stopped by another group
of soldiers and given an amnestic
he drove away never knowing how close he
had come to vanishing in the bowels of
scp 1861-a
sean was lucky that one of the scp
foundation's mobile task forces had
taken over the situation
but they were too late to help those who
had already complied with
scp-1861-b's orders and boarded the
wintershimer
the task force made it their business to
save whoever they could
but that wasn't their only directive the
foundation had recorded a huge number of
scp-1861 instances since 1916
and now they were finally going to
figure out what was going on
inside the foundation had already
discovered that those taken onto the
winter shimmer don't simply disappear
once on board the submarine they are
forced into a diving suit of their own
which transforms them into new instances
of scp-1861-b
upon realizing this foundation
scientists devised an ingenious plot
six months before this latest instance
of 1861
the foundation dispatched two members of
d-class personnel who were familiar with
one another
into the red mist one was instructed not
to interact with scp-1861-b
while the other named sal was ordered to
enter the submarine
his mission was to report back all
findings to foundation researcher dr
clutch during the next
1861 event the d-class who remained on
shore was brought in once more by the
mobile task force during the september
event that sean witnessed
they checked each diving suit wearing
anomaly until they heard
a familiar voice muffled by the mask it
was sal
and he'd been transformed into an
instance of scp-1861-b
the human d-class receiving questions
from dr clutch via remote broadcast
commenced the interview of his former
friend it is from this vital interview
that much of the foundation's knowledge
of the mysterious hms wintershimer is
drawn
according to sal the interior of the
winter shimmer which is a long narrow
passageway
is a spatial anomaly that seems to
stretch on forever
this explains how vast number of people
like the entire population of innsmouth
on sea
can disappear into the submarine at once
sal reported that
about an hour after entering the vessel
the hatch closed and the interior
began rapidly filling with water as the
submarine descended
prisoners of the winter shimmer were
faced with two choices
suit up or drown few chose the latter
option
and as soon as the suit was on the
transformation had begun
as soon as everyone was suited up and
the submarine had fully descended
causing the 1861 weather event to
dissipate on earth
the wintershimer had effectively entered
an alternate dimension
the airlock opened and the new recruits
were instructed to step outside and take
a look around
the wintershimer veterans informed the
new sailors that everyone on land was
likely already dead by this point
when sal first exited the submarine he
commented on everything
around him looking eerily similar to how
it looked on land before the mist
descended
but with one key difference it seemed as
though
everything was underwater well not quite
that
it was almost as though everything was
water
like the world had taken on a kind of
flowing liquid state
sal and the others existed in this
otherworldly land of living water for
six months
and as the months passed things only got
stranger
they found that they neither needed to
eat nor sleep
according to sal all they did was
breathe and pass the time by exploring
and talking to one another
anyone who attempted to take off their
suit would dissolve and diffuse into the
same liquid that surrounded them dr
clutch asked sal about the other
inhabitants of this alien realm
and this was when things got truly
disturbing there were dead humans and
animals floating all over the place
missing their eyes as though they'd been
scooped out and missing their mouths
as though they'd been bitten out of
their face by some kind of huge predator
their empty eye sockets bled constantly
and sal theorized that this may have
something to do with the anomalous blood
mists of scp-1861
when asked to provide more information
on why all the corpses were mutilated in
this way
sal said that one of his superiors on
the winter shimer told him
the watcher of eyes and biter of teeth
deemed them worthy
whatever this mysterious being was it
seemed to be a powerful figure within
1861's water world
and sal felt lucky that he never had a
direct run-in with the creature
himself for his final request dr clutch
asked sal to attempt to remove his suit
the foundation had learned in previous
instances of 1861 that the diving suits
have anomalous durability
and it was impossible for anyone other
than the wearer to remove them
hence why the foundation could never
deal with 1861-b
by using brute force naturally clutch
was interested in finding out what was
going on underneath
sal expressed fear and anxiety at first
wondering if after all he'd been through
whether he could ever be considered
human anymore eventually he was
convinced to remove the suit
and his worst fears were confirmed the
second cell removed his helmet
gallons of seawater poured out and the
now empty suit collapsed to the ground
sal's body was never found only some
teeth and a pair of eyes were recovered
the eyes were later confirmed to be
belonging to a young girl
and the teeth were identified as having
come from a european red deer
and so the dark mystery of the hms
winter shimmer continues
because of the unpredictable nature of
its appearances and the resulting
difficulty of containing it
the winter shimmer has earned a ketter
classification
the only containment procedure currently
employed by the scp foundation
is for mobile task forces to try and
intercept the submarine when appearances
are reported
and hopefully prevent or at least reduce
the kidnapping
of civilians with so many questions left
unanswered
all we can say for certain is that if a
red mist ever descends on you
and a stranger in a diving suit tells
you you're in grave danger
he's absolutely right now go check out
scp-035 the possessive mask
and scp-087 the stairwell for more
freaky stories from the scp
foundation